ι δια δηλώσεις όλα αυτά μας βοηθούν εμάς στους αστυνομικούς να κάνουμε καλύτερα τη δουλιά
μας αναι μααυτά χωρίς να υτικές φωτοβολίδες χωρίς κριγο να χωρίς έαντε χωρίς μάχες στο
παιδίοτκαι στους δρόμους λε πηγάμε σε άλλα επίπεδα και καιέρχεθε στο μυαλό μου υπερίπτωση τον
επισε ο δύο πρι ένα μιση χρόνο δύο χρόνια στο ελευθερία όπου έκανες μια παρέμβαση
που συζητήθηκε έντο ότι κάποιοι πήγαν να βειάσουν αν θυμάμε καλά όμέλως της όι μας
αρενόχλησα μας άρπαξα συναδέλφισα μα στην άρπαξαν μας στην απάγαγα για κλάγιαλίγα λεπτά οργανωμένι της
μιας μάδα μα στην άρπαξαν όπως ήταν για όνόμα του θεού εκείνεταην ημέρα μας άρπαξαν
σανέρθεσαν τετράβηζανται οκάτω και ότην εκτύπησαν και όλα αυτά είναι καταγραμμένα επρέπε δηλαδή να φτάσουμε
σσεσημεία όι πρέα φτάσουμε στο σημείο εμείς να λέγχουμε εμείς τηνα γαμνε πειχνίδι εμείς να
ωρίζουμε τους κανονες εμείς είμαστε ν υπευθυνι γιατί δημοσίαντα ξυγκρέόνεναν ούτε οι πρόίτερη το νομάδω
ούτε ο πρόδερος τους κόπ ούτε κανένας αμάνα πεθάνει κάποιοςνα τραμμαλιστεί καποιοσις τα ύπεδα και
είνός που να ατέ ξενάνοια στυνομία και κανένας άλλός παρά ι αστυνομία να θέτι τους
κανόνες και κανένας άλλος απειλές δεκτηκες ναι αλλά ν εφισε ολογικό α ποκάτι στην κύπρον
πάρα ξε έναα να πράμο να μίσαμε ότι ο ποιος δε εχετα απιλές ότι καπνις
ιο κάτοι σωστό ποιος δ ίχεταπιλές εφισολογικό μιο ναι δεκτικαπιλές που τα συφί που τες
κεντρικές φυλακές δεκτικά γιατί μίλησαικαβαριπινίτες και ιακατάδικους και γιατασυβή εφισολογιγό οι κντρικές φυλάκες ένα πρόβλημα
για όλη την κατάσταση ακόμα και στην αστυνομία πρόσφατα είδαμε ότι ένας βάρι πινήτης έκανενε
πότκα που εδιήρκησε εντελικά για αρκετόν καιροντο γύρισμα ι λείψει να πίστευτηση το κινητό έστειλε
το ελικό στο εξωτερικό άρα